morning everybody mass resignations a
late night reshuffle a prime ministerial
apology and the big question this
morning on everyone's lips
can boris johnson survive and if so for
how long this morning the prime minister
preparing for pmqs and facing questions
from mps at the liaison committee and
showing no signs of going anywhere
voluntarily
the chancellor rishi sunak and the
health secretary sajid javid are the
biggest resignations late last night the
solicitor general alex chalk also quit
as did the party's vice chair bim
afflami
two trade envoys andrew morrison and
theo clark and four parliamentary
private secretaries jonathan gullis
sachi bhatti nicola richard and virginia
crosby have also quit
nadim zahawi and steve barclay will be
stepping up to take up their new posts
as chancellor and health secretary
respectively
while michelle donald will take over
nadeem zahari's former post as education
secretary
a swathe of cabinets say they still
support the pm including the foreign
secretary liz trust the home secretary
pretty patel the culture secretary
nadine doris and the deputy pm dominic
raab
the defense secretary ben wallace
levelling up secretary michael gove
business secretary quasiquating and the
work and pension secretary that's to
raise coffee have also backed the prime
minister here's the latest from tomorrow
weakened by the resignations of two of
his most senior colleagues the question
dominating westminster and filling the
front pages this morning can the prime
minister cling on to power
glum faces at yesterday's cabinet in the
hours before the resignations later
today boris johnson faces prime
minister's questions and a grilling from
mps on the liaison committee
and while he moved quickly last night to
fill his cabinet vacancies with the
appointment of nadim zahawi as his new
chancellor a man himself tipped as a
possible leadership rival and chief of
staff steve barkley as health secretary
it's clear the prime minister is
battling to survive
the resignations came just as boris
johnson was apologizing for appointing
chris pincher as deputy chief whip
despite accusations of sexual harassment
boris johnson acknowledged he had been
told about a previous complaint
following days of denials from number 10
that that had been the case
in hindsight it was the wrong thing to
do i apologize to everybody who's been
badly affected
by it
i'm just gonna go spend some time with
my family thank you for coming sajid
javid was the first to resign making his
position clear in a letter to the prime
minister saying the tone you set as
leader and the values you represent
reflect on your colleagues your party
and ultimately the country
minutes later another body blow for the
prime minister as chancellor rishi sunak
quit too he said the public rightly
expect government to be conducted
properly competently and seriously i
recognize this may be my last
ministerial job but i believe these
standards are worth fighting for and
that is why i'm resigning
within the conservative party anger and
our knees has reached new levels in the
past few days
we can't go on like this
and i think that's going to be a matter
for all of my colleagues those in
government and those on the back benches
about what steps we now need to take to
deal with it
labour say mr johnson's time is up and
are calling for an election now
changing one man at the top of the tory
party won't make any difference he won't
fix the problems let's have a fresh
start for britain let's have a real
change of government
last month boris johnson narrowly
survived a vote of confidence in his
leadership
technically he's immune from another
such challenge for a year but tory
rebels could try and use elections to
the 1922 committee of tory back benchers
to change the rules tamara cohen sky
news westminster
the chancellor nadine zahawi is with us
this morning congratulations chancellor
thank you for joining us on the program
this morning um
what first attracted you to become
chancellor for a man described as a liar
a schemer a law breaker and without
integrity
you don't go into this
job to
have an easy life
you make some tough decisions every day
and
sometimes
it's easy to walk away but actually it's
much tougher to
deliver for the country if you look at
where we are today okay we are facing a
a global uh
battle against inflation inflation is
raging in germany and well come on the
u.s no but it's important yeah you're
asking me a question about why i'm doing
this job i'm doing it because i think
the team that is in government today is
the team that will deliver that will
deliver
today a tax cut for 30 million people
330 pounds today uh as we've moved the
threshold of national insurance up to
250 pounds 12 500 pounds forgive me um
and of course the work i was doing uh in
education on skills those runways for
people's careers to take off on we have
a tight labor market we know that yeah
so there's some big challenges facing us
and i do want to and i want to i want to
make sure we deal with those challenges
the people by the way who are eggs
egging us on to divide and to turn on
one another are people like alistair
campbell and wherever as the campbell is
you want to be on the opposite side of
the argument in my view okay so um
sometimes you said sometimes it's easier
to walk away did you think about it
no i'm just saying to you in life that
it's you know having to take tough
decisions as you do
when i was in vaccines when i'm in
education and now in the treasury there
are no easy answers the most important
thing to remember
is we've got a task ahead of us to
rebuild the economy we've just come out
from yeah what is the equivalent of of a
world war talk about the economy let's
do it and of course grow these did you
threaten to resign
no i didn't no i didn't threaten to
design at all because where do we come
from i wonder i i have apparently liz
trust was going to be
foreign uh it was going to the foreign
secretary was going to be chancellor and
you said if it's not me i'm stepping no
i haven't that that is that is
completely untrue and by no foundation
in reality absolutely by the way
this is a team game and you you play for
the team and you deliver for the nation
okay ultimately nothing to do with
personality focus has to be about
delivery okay that is the important
thing with personal ambition the no
because the right look
as i said to you sometimes you know
walking away um
yeah may give you some some you know
respite uh dare i say but the idea that
you have to deliver for the country
i think is the country that's given me
everything giving my family everything
is the right thing to do we have some
big challenges ahead of us we've got war
raging on our continent you know nobody
foresaw a war in uh in europe for
decades now you run as leader when
there's a vacancy
so do you run as leader when there's a
vacancy there's no vacancy the people
who are eggiest on to you know
turn on one another
are the people like alistair campbell
who will never vote conservatives
i'm saying to you
when there's a vacancy will you run the
odds are really good for you at the
moment ten to one
well first of all i will be working very
hard to make sure that this team
continues to deliver the prime minister
is focused on delivery delivery delivery
um i want to make sure that not only do
we rebuild the economy we've got to grow
uh the economy um yeah we had some good
growth the second growth fast-growing
country this year uh it's gonna come to
order it returns to that in 2024 it
grows again in 2025 but i've got to make
sure we get through 22 and 23
where you know we've got inflation um
which can be you know a really painful
thing if we let it um uh uh you know get
out of control and that is my focus it
has to be my friend let's talk about
policy then what immediate plans did you
make with the prime minister yesterday
when it comes to uh national insurance
when it comes to cutting taxes when it
comes to tackling inflation when it
comes to corporation tax what
conversations did you have during your
longer meeting yesterday so it's my
first day in the job uh the conversation
we had is my task is to
rebuild the economy and to grow the
economy uh i will look at everything uh
to make sure that we continue
to be on the side of people a tax cut
today of 330 pounds the first tax cut in
a decade
for 30 million people that's really
important 1200 pounds for 8 million
people who are really being squeezed by
this global battle against inflation
that's really important uh and
once i've
looked at the evidence i'll be very
happy to be back on your show kay and
share with you what i think we need to
do to rebuild and grow no i've got to
rebuild and grow the economy we've just
come out of the equivalent of a world
war and we've got war raging in europe
because of putin's illegal
uh invasion of ukraine we've got to deal
with these big things now i think to
indulge in infighting is the wrong thing
we've got to unite and deliver well you
wanted to move on to the economy so we
are we've predicted to have the slowest
economy growth in the g7 next year and
the highest inflation um our economic
outlook is just not very good isn't it
well i just said so we had the second
uh fastest growth this year um and we
said to return to that in 2024 the gap
is 2023 i want to look at what more i
can do to make sure we can return to
growth the important thing is to get
inflation under control you know be
fiscally responsible well i'll come back
on your program and very happily uh talk
to you about exactly how i'm going to
make sure that the first thing we've got
to do is make sure that you know we
are really careful about you know
whether it's public sector pay so
inflation doesn't continue to be fueled
that fire mustn't be fueled uh that will
cause even deeper and more painful
problems for exactly the people we're
trying to help with the tax cut today
those 30 million people are getting 330
pounds of attacks up today uh will
suffer the most if inflation's going to
do about corporation tax i will look at
everything there's nothing off the table
i want to be you know one of the most
competitive countries in the world for
investment i know that you know boards
around the world uh when they make
investment decisions they're long term
and the one tax they can compare
globally
is corporation tax and i want to make
sure uh that we are as competitive as we
can be uh whilst maintaining fiscal
discipline of course working with the
bank of england to make sure that
monetary
policy is right
for this country
and bringing inflation under control it
will abate i my task is to make sure it
happens as quickly as possible and to be
on the side of the you know the people
who are really hard-pressed which is why
today's tax teachers like teachers who
wanted a nine percent pay raise well
they wanted more you said that you would
offer them a nine percent pay raise now
that you're in a position to do that
will you still honor that i so the uh
pledge i will give teachers is um we
will do nine percent for uh the the
teachers that are starting in teaching
this year uh seven point seven percent
next year for them what about other
acceptance will they get the same and
senior teachers will get that five
percent that i've proposed um and i will
obviously look at the recommendation
from the pay review bodies across the
board uh where we're we're looking at
nine percent and then at new nurses
you're saying oh you can only get three
percent no no but what i've said to new
teachers is i want to get them to 30 000
pounds a year um the public sector
review uh bodies for health for
education for transport and elsewhere
we'll make recommendations and i will
look at those they're not going to be
even handed across the board you've got
you've got to look at the public sector
review bodies and then make sure you
follow the evidence and i will i'm
obviously working with my colleagues
across government the health secretary
steve barkley no what i'm saying to you
is the public sector review bodies uh
we've each secretary of state has made
their uh submission to those review
bodies they will come back to us we will
look at it very carefully and we'll
we'll make an announcement due course
what you're going to do about the energy
price cap in october um so again um yeah
we have got an energy price gap which
which actually does help people what
will happen in october is additional
help that that you know that grant that
mauritius sunk delivered so brilliantly
that will help people with the cost of
energy but of course while i look at
where energy prices are are then there
is a spike in energy you know that
because of the illegal uh uh occupation
of ukraine um and we've got to make sure
we have um
energy
um
strategy with the prime minister
delivered by the way um uh with
quasi-cuatang
that allows us to invest in nuclear
very very important investment which uh
labour decided to
divest from what are you gonna do about
field duty i will look at everything i'm
not going to make policy i'm not going
to play gotcha questions i don't know
how much i believe your petrol is but i
do want to know what you're going to do
about fuel gear it's my first day in the
job and i will look at everything i'll
be delighted to come back
you know the interview process last
night when you went in and said give me
the job as chancellor you must have had
some of the answers to some of these
questions well you know
my track record i hope in government
whether delivering the vaccine or in
education and now in the treasury is i
will look at the evidence and i will
share the evidence with the nation and i
will address exactly what we will do the
most important thing is to rebuild the
economy post pandemic and to get growth
going again and tax cuts we're
delivering the first tax cut in a decade
today i'm determined to do more uh boris
johnson's uh told 80 loyal mps yesterday
that it would now be easier to deliver
tax cuts um because uh rishi sunak is
not there anymore so i was rushing a bad
not at all uh you i'm sure uh read boris
johnson's letter to uh richie sunak and
of course i read that's left it to him
javid uh and rishi uh did an excellent
job as chancellor he's the 37 billion
pounds of help for those people who need
that help because of the global battle
against inflation in 12 months um
but you can't tell me what more is right
i'm gonna i'm gonna i hope repeat one
more time fiscal discipline bring
inflation under control
a tax cut today the first tax in a
decade um how are you going to do it so
i'm it's my first day in the job i'm
going to look at everything
every lever that's available to me
to make sure we get this right
ultimately we are on the side of people
who are at the moment struggling with
their weekly shops struggling with
paying those energy bills that's why
they're getting this tax cut today to 30
million people 330 pounds is so
important and you have told me that
three times no whatever i'll keep
repeating it yeah okay i've asked you
some of the other stuff that you can't
answer but you have promised to come
back so let's see uh whatever you do
about taxes though and whatever you do
about the cost of living it doesn't
erase the shame of this prime minister
defending sexual harassment at work does
it
so the prime minister gave an interview
last night where he spoke about
the mistake that the benefit of
hindsight he should have never
appointed chris pincher to deputy uh
chief whip i think
this government is determined to make
sure that
no one
abuses their position or power and
anybody who has a complaint should come
forward and make that complaint uh chris
pinch the allegations against
christopher were investigated in 2017 um
uh
were found not to be uh right he was
appointed by theresa may as a minister
continued in ministerial office the
allegations uh in the foreign office
were investigated and resolved at the
time with an apology from chris spencer
but with the benefit of hindsight the
premise is right the sex pastor he he is
right prime minister was right to
apologize and say that with the benefit
of hindsight it was the wrong
appointment
we make decisions
by name pincher by nature and you want
to serve as this man's chancellor okay
we make decisions at warp speed in
government there are no easy decisions
uh to make we don't get all those
decisions right it's right for the
parents to come forward and apologize
yeah but if somebody comes to you and
says this bloke you want to watch out
for him for what he's been up to you
know if somebody actually was faced safe
to face with the prime minister and he
did nothing about it and then he lied
about it well first of all we make
decisions
you know you know that the speed at
which we make decisions in government
especially dealing with a pandemic
dealing with a global battle against
inflation war on our continent um we
don't get every decision right the prime
minister was right to come out and say
look with the benefit hindsight i'm
sorry i made a mistake on appointing
chris pincher um that's the right thing
there's also but there's also due
process it's only right that we protect
people from any form of abuse or
any form of abuse of power
by anyone and actually anyone watching
this program should know that if they
work in government and for any mp or any
minister they can come forward um and uh
if they feel that in in any way being
right um uh abuse
that's the right thing to do okay that
culture is the right culture to
apologize is the right thing to do okay
we are nothing's ever easy um
and also rishi sunak both questioned the
integrity of this prime minister do you
think this prime minister has integrity
i do i think he needs to know well
because he's determined to deliver for
this country
good to talk to you thanks very much
indeed chancellor thank you uh let's
have a look at the odds uh should we and
four to one actually for rishi sunak liz
trust uh nine to one and as i said ten
to one for the new chancellor nadim
zahawi
looking at the papers for you
let's start with the telegraph should we
um boris johnson's premiership is
hanging on by a thread after the health
secretary and the chancellor resigned in
quick succession yesterday the guardian
says the pm is on the brink of losing
javid and sunak so too does the times uh
the mirror exclaims finally and calls
the prime minister toxic on its front
page but the daily mail asks whether
boris the greased piglet can wriggle out
of this and the metro says boris johnson
is still clinging on to power despite
those heavy blows the express takes a
different tone urging mr johnson to
fight on and cut taxes
at midday boris johnson takes to the
dispatch box for what's expected to be a
very lively prime minister's questions
and later in the day the pm will appear
before the liaison committee as he
fights to stay in his job
still to come on the programme for
you're going to be speaking to the
former conservative mp and ex attorney
general that's dominic grieve
discuss the chaotic events at
westminster with the spectator's deputy
political editor katie balls and former
conservative advisor claire purcell
and we'll hear from the conservative mp
sir roger gayle as he joins calls for
the prime minister to go
before all that though let's bring in
will walden who used to be the former
press secretary to boris johnson hi will
good to see you this morning talk me
through your phone okay
oh what a mess uh i mean what a total
mess uh i didn't hear all of nadeem
zahway he's he's a good man with it with
a tough job um but and i'm sure he was
manfully defending the prime minister
but the truth is we're sitting here this
morning um and once again
the prime minister has been front and
center of his own defense tradition um
nadeem's a hallway talked there about
you know how he'd come out and you know
he he'd he'd cleared up the record the
problem is that the record should have
been cleared up on friday when they
realized they were busted over pincher
they should have been honest about it
and whatever happened the prime minister
spoke to people over the weekend told a
very different story and then someone
busted that and he was caught again with
his hand in the cookie jar and i think
one thing's clear if the tories didn't
know that boris johnson wasn't going to
change and i think over the years chao
told you that he absolutely won't then
this morning for sure they know he won't
what they have is what they've got
i think that the problem for the prime
minister is that it seems now the
majority of you know dancing to a
different tune and moving in a different
direction to him
he's survived again though hasn't he
well he has for now um you know and in
in no small part in in in terms of
acting quickly but
what does that survival cost you know
nadine's a highway um you know as the
new chancellor um
you know it sounds like from some of the
reports this morning i don't know if you
asked him about it you know has um
fought a battle to become chancellor and
therefore you know he's won that battle
boris is apparently promising um the the
tax cuts are the answer i would just say
to uk can you run economic policy in
this country on the basis simply of
trying to stay in power
it feels like a pm being led rather than
a pm leading and that's the problem that
he's got and i think that the tone of
the resignations yesterday was was was
was visceral uh i think that that that
view
in part appears to in my mind to be
shared by at least some other cabinet
ministers but the truth is now that um i
think that the whole handling of the
pincher affair you know has demonstrated
to people boris won't change it just
like partygate there weren't any parties
oh yes there were i've now been caught
it's exactly the same with pincher and i
think that they're looking at the
polling you know now nearly 70 think he
he should go um and thinking that the
game is probably up and i think that if
there aren't further resignations and
that isn't enough then what we will see
is we will see rather than the 1922
committee changing the rules in six
months time or saying that they're going
to change them at a later date i think
they'll move very quickly against the
prime minister one thing to add kay you
know boris is not a quitter um i
remember
that we've been in the car about five
minutes after he resigned in 2016
because he wasn't going to stand anymore
because michael gave stabbed him in the
front and stabbed him in the back and
within five minutes of leaving that
press conference he looked at me and he
said
do you know what i think i made the
wrong decision here and i think that's
boris all over he will dig in he will
continue to fight whatever the odds
and the conservative party now is in
open warfare and they know that in order
to get rid of him they will have to
continue to move against him and it will
not be pretty in the coming days and
weeks
the chancellor um and you said he's a
man of um integrity himself he says that
the prime minister has integrity um what
do you make of that
i think that's the only thing you can
say in those circumstances you know i've
known boris a long time he is capable of
you know fantastic moments of personal
kindness in particular and i've been a
beneficiary of that
in the past he's you know he he's a very
um
lovable
open kind of guy but unfortunately um it
seems that to me that he's been busted
once too often in the job and i think
part of the problem is he had no
strategy no clear ideology he's been
buffeted of course by events he's had
three teams around him of different
iterations who all seem to have one
thing in common and that's the inability
to stand up to the prime minister and
just say stop sorry this you know let's
just game this out you know if on a
friday you suggest that you never knew
about this what happens if for some
reason if you did know about it and on
monday we have to reverse ferret and it
seems to me that over the years there's
been nobody there who's been really
really clear with him which just says
you know it can't go on like that that
is not a strategy for running this
country and i think as mayor of london
he was like the perfect
salesman he was the perfect presidential
kind of candidate over the water with no
opposition and no conservative party to
have to run running a government and
running the conservative party is a very
very different job and much as it pains
me he hasn't listened to to advice or
he's not been given the right advice and
he's made the same choices that he made
as mayor but it they've been proven
wanting in the bigger job of being prime
minister and i think that unfortunately
for boris johnson this probably only
ends one way it's not impossible that he
can survive but i think it's vanishingly
small and it ends in a in a tragic
defense tradition if he does not
uh decide that the best course of action
is to resign and he won't decide that
snap election
i doubt it because i think they'd lose
um i think they probably know that um
you know but equally they've got a
vanishingly small window if they do
choose to replace the prime minister um
because
you know you've got to have a situation
where a new leader
can get you know got very difficult task
ahead with the cost of living crisis can
get some traction some credibility some
some knowledge and you know i i i don't
know what nadeem zahawi's motives in
accepting the the job of chancellor i
think it's very difficult if you're
offered that job to to turn it down but
equally he is talked of if johnson were
to go
as a possible unifying candidate
and what he needed um you know was name
recognition uh and certainly by being
chancellor in the next few weeks or
months however long mr johnson survives
assuming that he does eventually go
then the chancellor has at least given
himself that by accepting the job but my
goodness he's got a task ahead
um if boris picked the phone up to you
today boris johnson and said come back
and sort all this out for me
very very unlikely what would i say to
him uh i think boris stopped listening
to me a long time ago i i i don't think
there's any way you can spin this now um
i think probably deep down he he knows
that it is a total car crash and a total
mess
but it is one that we need to remember
is not the fault of the media for you
reporting it it's not the fault of
people for listening here you know
apparently the latest excuse is that
it's his memory which is a fault um
the fault lies with the prime minister
and deep down you know he knows that um
and nothing short of wholesale change
will change that so i don't think
there's much i could say to him um this
morning except good luck mate
on that note thanks very much indeed for
joining us on the program always
appreciated thank you cheers kate take
care
you too
boris johnson's supporters say he won an
election majority of more than 80 just
two and a half years ago his detractors
point out there's little evidence he
would keep it in an election today just
heard that didn't we altering him is the
seat of segre and brady the power broker
on the conservative back benches who
could help dictate the prime minister's
future from there here's katarina
vertozzi
lock down parties groping allegations
and now cabinet resignations in
altringham in greater manchester an area
of traditionally strong conservative
support has patience with the prime
minister run out the lockdown stories
and the party gates and that's of thing
i mean you know and not enough i don't
think the prime minister should resign
though because
um if he resigned who would replace him
at the moment how many times can you say
oh i forgot i didn't know i was unaware
his other
are doing a terrible job or he's got a
terrible memory either way he's not
suitable for this job is he
in the local conservative club there is
deep frustration and not just towards
the man in charge i think it's just been
a slow slow death
and i don't think he's done anybody any
any favors himself included
the cabinets around him have got a lot
to answer for
um
and in my opinion
uh
well what's your next question going to
be well who would replace me that's
right
and for me it can't be any of the
cabinet because i think they're all
colored with the events of the last few
months but the last few months have also
involved a cost of living crisis and a
war in europe within their own family
the chogadis don't know if this is the
right time for change boris johnson
should not resign because um surely at
this point if the change of government
will give more upheaval to the to the
country uh rishi shanak and sajid javid
have been
through him through all these other
times and this has been the last draw
for them i think for quite a lot of
other mps it might also be as well and
if they go will more voters even in
areas like this one follow
catherine of autopsy sky news in greater
manchester
uh did you miss our interview with the
chancellor we'll show you some of it
again in just a second and also dominic
grieve will be joining us and sir ed
davey and the shadow chancellor the list
goes on and on stay tuned
a short while ago i spoke to the newly
appointed chancellor nadeem zahawi um i
asked him all sorts of things in
including gcse level questions about the
economy he said it was his first day in
the job he also told me a little bit
more about what he wanted to see happen
over the next few weeks and months
we've got a task ahead of us to rebuild
the economy we've just come out from
yeah what is the equivalent of of a
world war ii talk about the economy
let's do it and
no i didn't no i didn't threaten to
design at all because should we come
from i wonder i i have apparently liz
trust was going to be foreign
the foreign secretary was going to be
chancellor and you said if it's not me
i'm stepping no i haven't
absolutely by the way
this is a team game are you runners
leader when there's a vacant there's no
vacancy the people who are eggies on to
turn on one another
are the people like aleister campbell
who will never vote conservatives
are talking about the government when
there's a vacancy will you run the odds
are really good for you at the moment
ten to one
well first of all i will be working very
hard to make sure that this team
continues to deliver javid and also
rishi sunak are both questioned the
integrity of this prime minister do you
think this prime minister has integrity
i do i think he needs to know well
because he's determined to deliver for
this country
former conservative mp dominic grieve is
with us now hello to you thanks for
joining us on the programme um your
thoughts reactions first of all
the decision of the two senior ministers
to resign
is a massive indictment of boris
johnson's
uh lack of moral scruples and his
behavior and his capacity for lying
and i have to say i'm listening to nadim
whom i know
um i think he will regret having taken
on this job because his view of the
prime minister
is seriously flawed this is a prime
minister who's actually delivering
almost nothing what this prime minister
is delivering is chaos and the chaos
he's delivering is underpinned by his
charlatanism and his serial lying on
which he has been very clearly caught
out
in the incident involving mr pincher and
it's small wonder therefore that trust
in him in the prime minister is
completely collapsing i know that the
solicitor general has resigned as well
and i'm not surprised
still there though isn't he he's he's
the great survivor of this prime
minister
he is a great survivor i have no doubt
about that at all but equally it's right
to say that he's doing colossal damage
and and he's doing damage to the country
that really troubles me he's also
damaging the conservative party uh if he
continues in office the conservative
party will be destroyed by him and come
the next election it will suffer the
consequences of keeping a scoundrel in
office
and so each and every one of them is
going to be tainted
by their failure to take action to get
rid of somebody who is manifestly
unsuitable to hold office
snap election might not save him
i doubt very much it will save him i
would have thought it was a snap general
election uh and he decided to call one
he is going to
take the conservative party to its doom
um i'm never going to vote conservative
again as long as he is uh prime minister
and i think that's quite a widespread
point of view uh which i share with my
neighbors who many of whom are
conservative voters as well
just before i let you go a lot of mps
and certainly cabinet ministers and even
the prime minister very scared of the
1922 committee i wish i had some music
there to go
why are they so scared about it
because the 1922 committee ultimately
has the power to unseat him it can
change its own rules uh to hold another
vote of confidence
uh or vote of no confidence in the prime
minister uh and i would have thought
that the accumulating problems the prime
minister has means that he is very close
to forfeiting support from a majority of
his back of his members of parliament
any ordinary prime minister
faced with this catalogue of failure and
collapse
and of his own misbehavior would have
been long gone
this prime minister by nature and
temperament is not going to go
so as i've said on the previous occasion
his fingers have to be priced off the
window nature i'm afraid and that is
going to be the task of conservative
back bench mps and they've got to get on
with it because if they don't the
conservative party is finished
thanks for joining us much appreciated
tomorrow at downing street for us this
morning um very uncomfortable viewing
for the pm so far this morning
it certainly has been kay and the prime
minister make no mistake is really
clinging to office at the moment he
needs to try and make this work we heard
from his new chancellor nadeem zahawi we
had yesterday two senior members of the
cabinet who many see as leadership
contenders in a future contest deciding
to break cover and go and say we can't
do this anymore nadeem zaha we decided
to take that promotion and stay some
conservative mps are skeptical about how
that may pan out for him but he's
clearly decided that taking the most
senior job he may be offered is the
right move and he gave a strong
indication of a difference in approach
once he gets going saying that tax cuts
are on the agenda and he wants to go
aggressively for growth now the message
i'm getting from downing street sources
this morning is that the prime minister
didn't waver last night he still feels
very strongly that he has this mandate
from 14 million people who voted for him
back in 2019 and he will try to deliver
but it wasn't just the two big names he
went last night there were nine
resignations in total including those
from the junior ranks and who knows we
may get some more today there are
suggestions that we may do and many of
those letters from people who had
previously been supportive criticize the
prime minister's seriousness competence
and integrity and as more and more
conservatives feel that the ship cannot
be turned around now the prime minister
will be hoping his new top team can try
to do so but for many conservatives this
sounds like a reset too far
okay tomorrow thank you
roger gail sir roger girl is with us now
hi good morning good morning um it's
still there the prime minister is is the
arch survivor
he has a great instinct for
self-preservation
the unfortunate thing is that it's about
him
not about the country not even about the
conservative party
it's all about mr johnson
and his desire to survive
we can't go on like this
it was the country that put him in that
position and we just had the new
chancellor exactly where you are saying
that he's a man of integrity so he still
has loyal supporters within the party i
don't well i'm quite sure he does have
supporters
uh i know that he has supporters out in
the country
some people think that he can walk on
water
i'm not one of those people i'm afraid i
don't share the chancellor's view
of his integrity and i don't think that
simon mcdonald's letter yesterday
indicates that and i don't think that
sajid javi's resignation letter
indicates that they were both
devastating
the fact the matter is
the prime minister one way or the other
has to go and if he won't go
voluntarily then the parliamentary
conservative party is going to have to
remove him
well no no dean sahar would be a good uh
chancellor do you think
i think he's a very able man
no question at all i think he's a very
good chancellor with that without any
question i mean he played a blinder he
he delivered
the vaccine rollout that the prime
minister took the credit for
but it was not him zawi who did that i
have no question whatsoever that he will
be a perfectly
good chancellor
um not prime minister though he's
telling us because he's doing the job
because he wants to be loyal to the
prime minister um he says he didn't
offer he didn't threaten to resign if
liz trust got the job he sat there and
said he did and what do you think
well
he has to make his own decisions
he's chosen to throw his weight in
behind the present prime minister
in so doing he's probably
removed any prospect of his own
leadership chances for the moment
interesting you said that's roger
because i mean wasn't it michael
hesseltine who said that um the first to
jump is the one that will never be prime
minister that is absolutely true yeah
that is absolutely true the man who
wields the knife or the woman who wields
the knife
is virtually certain not to get the job
true though i mean i was thinking about
i was thinking about that didn't isn't
that what people like boris johnson did
to theresa may isn't that what um we saw
with maggie thatcher and ted's heath
isn't that what we saw with um oh i
don't know uh gordon brown and tony
blair
they didn't wield the knife they got
other people to wear before
and and i think that's that well there
is i mean that's what a clever person
does um
you know i have a preference for knifing
people in the front but there are plenty
of people in the party who knife people
in the back
so
we were expecting potentially more
high-profile resignations last night
they didn't come that means that the
prime minister is safe for now he's you
know you've got his fingertips on the uh
window ledge of number 10. but what is
the 1922 committee i was just putting
that to mr gork the 1922 committee can
get involved now just explain to us
because my viewers at home won't
necessarily know who the 1922 committee
are why are they so powerful 1922
committee is the committee of the whole
conservative back bench
it's powerful because it is the back
bench it's not what is known as the
payroll vote the payroll vote is
ministers and ministerial aides even
though they're not paid
but
they don't have a vote in the 1922
committee
the 22 committee can
which is chaired by segregation brady
can change the rules
i've said up until now i don't believe
we should change the rules in the middle
of the game but the game has changed i
think simon mcdonald's
letter and javi's letter
have shifted
the goal post very significantly indeed
mr johnson ought to go with dignity
he's clearly not going to
the only way therefore that we can
remove him is by having another
no-confidence vote
and in order to do that within 12 months
we do have to change the rules i don't
like it
because that is what the prime minister
chooses to do on occasions
but i think we're going to have to do it
and i suspect that the 22 committee will
do exactly that if the prime minister
doesn't resign and there's further
complication um particularly for the
prime minister because the executive of
the 1922 committee is up for re-election
correct
when
uh i think the nominations close today
exactly and the election therefore will
be next week but the current committee
could do it uh unt until there's a new
committee the current committee is valid
so
under segregame's chairmanship it could
be done
today do you think it will be
i don't know
what's your crystal ball telling you for
the next few weeks ahead of recess when
parliament rises for the summer which i
think is at the end of this month
we are staggering aren't we from crisis
to crisis
nobody knows what's coming around the
corner next
a week ago we weren't talking about
chris pincher
then everybody was talking about chris
pincher and then everybody was talking
about the way in which the prime
minister
lied about what he knew about chris
pincher
um
that was unforeseen a week ago so i
can't tell you what's going to happen
next week never mind what's going to
happen next month
but my prediction
for what it's worth which may not be a
lot
is that the prime minister will be gone
by the autumn and maybe sooner
before party conference
i would think so
we talk about you know what's happening
at number 10 and that stellatious gossip
or otherwise some of which is proven to
be fact and the prime minister
investigated here there and everywhere
but he's a colossus on the world stage
they think he's fantastic
everywhere he's been rwanda
um the g7 in
um
in bavaria um the uh nato meeting in
madrid everywhere he's been he's been
dogged by reporters
asking him about his
personal
attitude to government
instead of talking about the things that
really matter
and even internally
his ministers have been send out to
defend the indefensible
young minister a very bright young
minister
was here on monday morning will quince
will having to explain
what the prime minister had done instead
of talking about the thing that he was
supposed to be talking about
which was child care costs
we ought to be talking or don't we
about the cost of living we ought to be
talking about fuel we ought to be
talking about the war in ukraine which
is
terrifying
this is a distraction and it goes on
being a distraction after distraction
after distraction we cannot continue
like this we've got a good government
we've got good policies we've got good
ministers
but they're being badly led
we appreciate you taking the time to
join us on the programs roger this
morning thank you very much indeed thank
you thank you
uh what's happening at number 10 this
morning well um tamara is there for us
and she will be updating us in just a
moment or two we haven't seen the prime
minister yet today and we did see um
going through that um
impressive black door just last night he
went went in as education secretary came
out as chancellor nadim zahawi of course
and he
spoke to us on the program this morning
you can find out what he had to say for
himself
in just a short time but let's get some
more analysis before that should we the
spectators deputy political editor katie
balls
and former conservative adviser claire
purcell are here in the studio great to
see you ladies thanks for taking the
time katie to you first of all um moving
quickly now isn't it
yes
um i think there's obviously been a
build-up in terms of unhappiness in the
tory parliamentary party towards boris
johnson since the beginning of this year
and i think there's been a few points in
that period where it's seen is this the
day is this the day it breaks and
actually yesterday that was when the
mood really turned and boris johnson is
still in 10 downing street i think it's
probably still ambitious uh that mps
will manage to remove him before the
summer recess not impossible but there
is increasing sense amongst i think uh
tory mps that is game over
class
yeah i think we started to see the mood
change from friday evening there was a
lull in deciding what to do with
christopher pincher and i think that
left a lot of mps feeling very very
uncomfortable that led into the weekend
where you saw yet more headlines coming
through yet more indecision and it's
culminated in the events of last night
which is quite incredible what has
happened and i think we'll see
more today especially given we've got
pmq's coming up at midday and then the
liaison committee this afternoon where
the prime minister will be getting a
grilling from tory mps who are quite
mostly rebels and just to clarify for my
viewers this morning the liaison
committee is the chairpeople of all of
the other committees of that's right
select committee chairs go in and they
will have questions to the prime
minister this afternoon so i think this
is going to be some really uncomfortable
time for boris johnson i'm not sure he's
going to come out of it very well
how do you see events developing over
the next week well i agree that i think
in today if you could have imagined a
bad day for boris johnson i think this
is it the fact that he has a liaison
committee grilling i i think is
particularly awful timing for the prime
minister he wants to obviously push on
through this
and i think we saw last night when boris
johnson addressed loyal mps so this
group of mps that earlier this year
formed the save boris operation he
addressed them early evening after he
knew the chance that rishi sunik had
resigned and he suggested that tax cuts
would be easier now now you've heard
from the new chance the nadeem sahory
this morning but i think it does just
show you how boris johnson is not going
to go easily he's going to keep on
fighting and i think uh loads of random
is still wondering
could he think about stepping down it
seems very unlikely and therefore i
think we're in for really messy weeks
and few months potentially and it's
possible this drags out into the autumn
and i think if the prime minister
doesn't want to play by convention um i
think if this was theresa may we'd be
talking about conversations about a
resignation speech a graceful exit if if
he doesn't want to do that it becomes
quite unpredictable but the recess when
parliament rises for the summer that
could be his friend because if he's not
there potentially there's no mps there
causing mischief for him and we we
bumble on uh during the summer thinking
about our own holidays and then he comes
back um refreshed
it's a bit of a double-edged sword
though if you think about it just
because you're not in parliament doesn't
mean that those mps aren't going to be
talking to each other talking to their
constituencies
and conservative associations
there is a lot of unrest out here in the
country i see it when i speak to
residents in my area people are unhappy
and just because it's the summer
holidays and the weather might be
getting a bit better it doesn't mean
they've forgotten what's going on
and we are still without a party
chairman ten days after oliver dowden
resigned we're still without one so any
vice chair as well did didn't the vice
chair is absolutely live on air last
night we've had a vice chair leave so if
you were looking at uh trying to bring
your party together that suddenly there
is no real
comparable person in charge of anything
so any campaigns any local elections
that may or may not happen
i think you're you're into some really
difficult territory so he may not be in
westminster but i don't think he's going
to get an easy ride
can he survive can he survive at all
under any
circumstances i don't think anything is
impossible in politics
as we've seen in recent years i think
it'd be very surprising at this point i
mean i found it hard to find an mp
probably other than boris johnson
himself he thinks that he is going to
lead the party into the next election
right now
but you know politicians do surprise i
think the best hope for boris johnson
has somehow improved his popularity but
if you look at the immediate and then i
think mps might follow suit because
ultimately mps are worried about their
seats but if you look at the snap
holding last night in terms of what
boris johnson should do following those
resignations is not good for the prime
minister and also it looks as though
events are only going to get worse for
him you get to the autumn there's the
privileges committee interwelling he
misled parliament on the issue of
partygate that could be a crunch point
there's also party conference as you
mentioned earlier in the show that is
where boris johnson is going to come
face to face with tory grassroots
activist they used to be one of his best
assets now it feels as though the mood
has turned and then there's still the
ongoing cost of living crisis now the
new chancellor may adopt a different
approach we could get tax cuts sooner
but it's still a very grim economic
picture and it means it's so hard to
find this gears he can pull to change
the situation around him just looking at
the snap polling from yougov um
apparently 69
of people think that the prime minister
should resign and 54 of tory voters 2019
uh tory voters think he should resign
and 58 percent of leave voters think he
should resign so that's pretty grim
reading for him
it is because all the narrative so far
has been this is the fault of uh
remainer mps or remainer party members
and it plainly isn't i think the brexit
argument is is long gone
but that was what boris johnson stood on
so everybody is looking at that and
looking at these events under that prism
i don't think it matters people are
looking at the character of the man at
the top and are deciding that he is not
right for that job um
what for what future for sadie javid and
rishi sooner
well i think
the sense amongst tory mps is there will
be a leadership contest we just don't
know when
um and i think that both are seen as
contenders within that leadership
contest i do think we have a tricky
point though in the sense that
um there are clearly some in the cabinet
right now i think are also leadership
contenders while lots of people saying
they backed the prime minister
um i also think you know you have
something like nadine sahara who's being
talked up and i think we'll be talked up
even more now he's chancellor people
like liz truss
ben wallace
how does this play out in terms of mps
we get to leadership contest because
they're i think they're about 100 mps
who are still truly loyal to boris
johnson if you look at that same forest
group how are they going to be able to
get behind someone like richie sueno
called javid i imagine there'll be bad
blood there about the decision they made
to resign and but at the same time
there's so much unhappiness amongst all
the backbenchers who already called for
boris johnson to go at the ministers who
still you know remain in cabinet so i
think any leadership contest is going to
be very very messy
and i think it's quite interesting you
mentioned the the loyal mps and it's
worth noting that only 80 of them were
there last night out of 350 conservative
mps that's a really small number so i'm
not sure he's got quite the backing that
he thinks and now he's even in a worse
position because you have uh rishi sunak
and sajid javid on the back benches
where they are well liked well respected
and can galvanize the troops even
further i think this is pretty dangerous
territory okay ladies we are out of time
fascinating stuff thanks very much for
coming in this morning we really
appreciate it thank you
so
big question what happens next for boris
johnson clinging to power this morning
in number 10 downing street will he be
able to wriggle his way out of this one
[Music]